worthy Avengers we can bust arms dealers
all the live long day but that up there
that's that's a game Tony there was no
other way
[Music]
everybody it's Charlie so the big news
this morning is that everybody thinks
that the cinematographer from Avengers
for an Avengers infinity war revealed
the title on his own personal website so
I'll explain what I think is going on
because it's a title that people had
talked about before but then the Russos
came out and provided some context for
where the title would pop up and the
clues that people were looking in but we
also need to talk about dr. Strange's
secret plan so if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get all the Marvel videos we're
obviously going to be getting a whole
bunch of stuff all the way through Comic
Con there's a whole bunch of infinity
war blu-ray giveaway stuff that I'll
explain at the end of the video too so
first things first what is the title
that he revealed late last night early
this morning twitter blew up when the
cinematographer from the last two
Avengers films infinity war and Avengers
for Trent palak updated his website with
his resume in it said Avengers infinity
war and then more recently Avengers
endgame so naturally people like wait a
minute this is a guy that was on set
constantly for these two films why would
he put avengers end game on his own
personal website if he didn't think that
that was the title like this isn't some
where you post jokes this is the website
where you tell people in the industry
the stuff that you've worked on so that
they'll hire you for other stuff like
look at all the awesome movies that I've
done this is freaking half a billion
dollars worth of production budget
predictably it started spreading around
to the big news sites so that within a
couple hours he had changed it without
much fanfare to Avengers 3 infinity war
in Avengers 4 did somebody a Marvel
threaten his family if he didn't change
it immediately yes definitely but why
did they ask him to change it is it
because it's a secret they don't want
him to reveal the title or was it
because that's the incorrect title it
was one of the working titles while the
film was happening but not what the film
is actually going to be called when they
reveal it later this year like Kevin
Feige said so if you don't know Kevin
Feige finally said that they're actually
going to reveal the Avengers 4 title
right after they dropped the Captain
Marvel teaser within the next couple of
months they're winding down on Captain
Marvel in the next week or two then
they'll cut a teaser they'll release
that in a couple months
then they'll reveal that Avengers 4
title then after that we'll find out
when we get that first Avengers 4
footage but the whole thing is with this
Avengers end game title is as that was
one of the earliest guesses that people
had the Russos claim that the title
itself is never spoken as dialogue
during infinity war it as you saw in the
teaser that I put at the beginning of
this Doctor Strange speaks the words end
game so if the title isn't spoken during
infinity war at all and he says end game
therefore Sherlock burrows concurs the
title of Avengers 4 cannot be endgame
but that still doesn't answer the
question as to why the cinematographer
who's actually a pretty important person
on set and was there the whole time for
both of these two movies for the last
couple of years put the end game title
on his website there's been a saga of
working titles associated with these two
films so I think behind closed doors
they called it a couple different things
that's why he's calling it endgame on
his website because remember originally
like when guardians 2 came out so he saw
Donna did an interview saying that she
was going back to film Infinity Gauntlet
at the end of the year talking about
Avengers 4 can you tell us if you're in
infinity war I think that the Guardians
just shot their part when it comes to
infinity Wars like the first part and we
all have to go back for gauntlets later
this year that was probably very briefly
the working title for Avengers infinity
war but the thing is is they don't tell
the actors anything that they don't need
to they didn't even tell them about the
ending of infinity war about everybody
getting turned to dust or gomorrah
getting thrown off the cliff on voir Mir
till the day that they filmed that stuff
because we spoke I spoke to Elizabeth
and T'Pol Bette and Elizabeth awesome
Paul Bettany this morning and we were
talking about the ending of infinity war
and they said that like the Russos
pulled them into a van and right before
they shot the scene they were like this
is the ending of the movie that's how
they found out about did you get the van
treatment as well I know the van they're
talking about I didn't I I said I'm not
going in that van
a few arrays right you had smart parents
I was like I want to be around people
when they tell me this but but yeah it
was like this is when you disappear and
I was like what does that mean Kevin
Feige then came out later and said no
it's definitely not Infinity Gauntlet I
think he also separately said that it
was not endgame as well the Russos
interview was just a more confirmation
like no the title has not spoken during
infinity war there are no actual clues
to be found in the dialogue that's
spoken remembering that a lot of it hit
the cutting room floor there may have
been some clues in some other line that
they ended up cutting you all probably
saw the logo that they were walking
around on set like obviously they have
to put the logo on everything while
they're filming they used the purple
Hawkeye logo for Avengers 4 mostly I
think as a joke because of while
infinity war was happening in they were
releasing teasers people started
freaking out about the lack of Hawkeye
so they're like okay we're gonna have a
little bit of fun with this hawkeye is
gonna be important in Avengers 4 maybe
not the most important person but
definitely critical so we'll give him
some props and use his purple for the
logo but this really only appeared on
crew jackets like anywhere you would see
the working title pop up so I think we
can just chalk this all up to the fact
that endgame at one time behind closed
doors
was what they called the movie with the
intention of it not being the final
title the Russos Kevin Feige actually
said that they came to the real title of
Avengers 4 pretty early in the process
of breaking both of the two stories but
what probably happened is is they
probably didn't want to tell anybody
like they didn't tell the actors that
they were gonna die till the last day
that they had to the gauntlet the
endgame titles all probably happened
pretty early in the process so like
we'll just refer to it as this but this
isn't going to be the actual title
recently they had the presentation where
they showed off some footage they had
Hulk in the armor Kevin Feige said that
Avengers 4 was going to be all about the
Avengers learning to work together as a
true team to become true heroes one of
the most iconic comic book movie moments
in history is The Avengers Assemble
scene from that first Avengers film so
obviously it's very important that the
original Avengers were some of the only
people to survive the end of infinity
war that scene is probably part of the
core idea of Avengers 4 so the closest
the Russos have said that anybody have
come to the title is Avengers forever
but that's not the title either so I
think we just have to assume that there
are only a handful of people that
actually know what the real title is and
they're just sitting on it because they
don't want it to get out but what about
dr. Strange's plan like I said that
Avengers Assemble moment he probably saw
that they needed to come together like
this concept art for Avengers 4 they
needed to have their Avengers Assemble
moment in take Thanos down together
working as a true team and in order for
that to happen they had to turn over the
time stone so the Thanos could snap his
fingers erase half of all life in the
universe which would lead to Nick Fury
calling for Captain Marvel so like he
saw all these dominoes falling in this
one instance where they would finally
end up winning but I've already done a
couple videos about what's going on with
the characters that died what's going on
with the plot of Avengers for all the
concept art so I'll link that stuff at
the end of this there's obviously gonna
be a whole bunch of news about Avengers
4 dropping in the next couple of months
so just leave all your requests in the
comments below what'll happen is is they
just confirmed that they're doing a halo
live-action TV series it's actually
finally happening now remember they
announced that in 2013 and it's taken
this long to get there we also learned
all about the first episode of Titans so
I'll do a video for that tomorrow
because it is hard core but there is a
new round of that infinity war blu-ray
giveaway going on all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video congratulations to
the winner from my last video envoy Eli
please private message me so I can get
your contact details I'll name a new
winner when I post new Marvel but click
here to learn all about the Doctor
Strange sequel and Avengers 4 and click
here to learn all about the Avengers 4
art that they just dropped thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]